This is the first part of a three-part illusion.
What do you see?
Well, there's a window and it's turning...
Except it stops and reverses direction.
I'm going to attach this Rubik's Cube to the short side of the trapezoid.
Okay the Rubik's
Cube is going around... but now, what is that?
It looks like the Rubik's Cube
is continuing to go around
but the window is oscillating back and forth.
Okaynew plan, I'm going to take off the Rubik's Cube
and I'm going to put a ruler right through the
middle of the window.
Okay the ruler is rotating
around but wait now the window is going backwards!
Whoa whoa the ruler is going through the window
it is doing things which I know are physically
impossible but that is how my brain is seeing it.